Вони стали відомими через участь у різних спецопераціях на боці України - на острові Зміїний, у Новій Каховці та у Брянській області.
Це бійці Російського добровольчого корпусу - етнічні росіяни, які емігрували з РФ і живуть в Україні чи інших європейських країнах.
На початку повномасштабного вторгнення вони долучилися добровольцями до різних підрозділів, зокрема "Азова".
Згодом постало питання легалізації цих бійців у складі ЗСУ.
Вже як Російський добровольчий корпус ми почали функціонувати десь наприкінці літа 2022-го.
Тоді все ще була проблема з оформленням, багато обіцяли, але нічого не відбувалося.
І ми в якийсь момент вирішили: давайте просто створимо бренд, тобто певну групу, яка матиме свою назву,
свій певний авторитет на фронті, свою впізнаваність. І так виник РДК.
Зараз бійці не розголошують свою приналежність до підрозділів ЗСУ.
Кажуть лише, що підпорядковуються Міністерству оборони України.
А їхні добровольці проходять кілька етапів перевірки - у самому підрозділі і в українських спецслужбах.
На запит DW Міноборони цю інформацію на момент виходу сюжету не підтвердило.
На початку формування РДК туди відбирали всіх охочих воювати на боці України.
Нині - шукають насамперед тих, хто вже має бойовий досвід.
І, зрозуміло, нам потрібні мотивовані люди, які розуміють, куди вони їдуть,
які хочуть цим займатися, які мають повне уявлення про те, куди вони їдуть і навіщо.
Тобто ідейні, скажімо так. Ідеологічні ідеалісти, які розуміють, що вони їдуть не по зарплатню,
не за грошима, не за пригодами, не за документами.
А вони їдуть брати участь у війні, вони їдуть боротися проти всієї тієї штуки, що йде зі сходу.
На питання, за що воюють бійці Російського добровольчого корпусу, відповідають так.
Насамперед РДК воює за Україну, за свободу України. Тобто для нас це таке завдання номер один.
Наша основна мета на сьогодні - це перемога України на умовах України в цій війні. І далі там є ще певні прагнення.
Ми б хотіли, щоб надалі запустився політичний та юридичний процес щодо трибуналів, репарацій,
пошуку та покарання всіх причетних до цієї війни з боку РФ.
І наступний крок - це повний демонтаж державної системи, яка зараз є у Росії. Повний демонтаж, повна люстрація.
У лавах РДК нині воюють сотні бійців. Деякі з них відомі своїми праворадикальними поглядами.
Крім колишніх кадрових військових, у Російському добровольчому корпусі воюють і цивільні -
студенти, скрипалі, автослюсарі, будівельники, підприємці.
Хтось переїхав в Україну чи виїхав за кордон уже після початку повномасштабного вторгнення,
інші - живуть в Україні вже багато років. Один із них - Ілля Богданов.
Колишній ФСБшник приїхав в Україну ще у липні 2014 року, щоб воювати на боці України проти агресії РФ.
Тригером стало, коли всі мої найкращі друзі поїхали воювати в той бік, тоді ще в "Новоросію".
І я пам'ятаю, я ще на службі був, мені приходить фотографія.
Там Федя, мій найкращий друг, у козачій папасі, з кулеметом,
сидить у білому ОБСЄ-шному джипі і розповідає, як він його відібрав, ОБСЄ-шника вигнали.
Потім переводить кадр, показує лінію з чоловіків, напевно від 18 до 40 років, такого маргінального вигляду, вони дуже віруючі були.
Він каже, що, мовляв, це мої розстрільні, сьогодні я їх розстріляю, бо вони не вписуються в наше нове російське православне суспільство.
І ось це стало тригерною точкою, ця несправедливість, щоб їхати в Україну.
Якою бачить кінцеву мету своєї участі у війні?
Я загадую і чітко бачу сценарій, коли українська армія виходить на межі 91-го року.
Що далі? А далі потрібна демілітаризована зона.
Без неї ніякий сучасний збройний конфлікт у 21 столітті точно не закінчується.
Ця зона має бути з якого боку: українського чи російського? Якщо з українського, то це, виходить, ті самі ДНР, ЛНР, так?
Ми це вже проходили, такого не буде. Значить, це буде Брянська область, це Курська область, Білгородська область.
Бійці РДК кажуть: повертатися в Росію будуть хіба що на танках.
Ось на танку, так. Там дуже злі люди, дуже велика різниця, яма між менталітетом українського населення та російського, просто величезна яма.
Я колись, не пам'ятаю де, але в Києві вже побачив футболку, я раніше не чув цього вислову,
мовляв, у Рашці ж, як завжди кажуть, "моя хата з краю, я нічого не бачив". А в Україні я бачив футболку: "моя хата з краю, я, мовляв, ворога зустріну першим".
Ось уся різниця життя в Росії та в Україні.
Данило з позивним "Шайба" приїхав в Україну нелегалом у 2021 році.
Каже, до того політикою не цікавився взагалі, хоч і був кадровим військовим. Лише в Україні відчув, як живуть вільні люди.
Тому коли почалося повномасштабне вторгнення, не вагався: почав оббивати пороги українських військкоматів і проситися у добровольчі формування.
Просто дивишся відео десь в Одесі і так далі, за чоловіками бігають, щоб вручити повістку.
А тут ти сам хочеш добровільно піти захищати український народ, землю та територію - а тебе не беруть .
Я хотів стати на захист України, оскільки я вирішив переїхати, перейти, почати життя в Україні, і мені тут дуже сподобалося.
І, знову ж таки, повторюся про свободу слова, взагалі, як живуть тут люди.
Просто хто не жив у Росії, важко пояснити, як це жити в цьому бл*… ГУЛАГу і як жити в Україні.
У лавах РДК Данило брав участь у військових операціях на запорізькому та херсонському напрямках.
У складі спецпідрозділу ГУР був у нічному рейді до Нової Каховки, завдяки чому українська розвідка
отримала дані про кількість, склад і місце розташування ворожих резервів.
На Каховку я плавав, операція "Червоний Дніпро". Чотири човни було, і ось наш човен РДК був четвертим номером.
"Висадка в Нормандії" відпочиває, хто фільм дивився, подивіться, це дитячий садок.
Ми мали провести розвідку боєм, звідки у них підтягуватимуться резерви, виявлення резервів, взагалі скільки часу у них на реагування...
Часто бійці РДК виконують завдання у так званій сірій зоні, за лінією фронту.
Вони працюють як піхота, розвідники, артилеристи, річковий та морський десант, сапери, мінери.
На боці України брали участь в багатьох військових операціях, зокрема у Брянській області, розповідає голова штабу РДК.
Основна мета Брянської операції головним чином була пропагандистською.
Ми хотіли за допомогою цієї операції показати громадянам Росії, що потрібно, і можна, і можливо боротися з існуючим режимом -
головне, було би бажання, була би воля до цього. Тобто можна знайти зброю, можна чинити опір.
Якщо вже ми зайшли навіть з-поза меж Росії, то вже в самій Росії це тим паче можливо,
було би бажання людей і правильна організація, правильна підготовка. За великим рахунком,
ми намагалися сказати і сказали, що настав час людям брати долю в свої руки, не треба нікого чекати, не треба нічого терпіти,
якщо ви хочете щось змінити - ви можете це зробити.
Я думаю, що Україна у будь-якому разі переможе, Україна в будь-якому разі вийде на межі 1991 року.
Україна в будь-якому разі наведе лад на окупованих нині територіях.
І я думаю, що Україна стане таким цивілізаційним центром Східної Європи, яким вона була ще у 10 столітті.